[MUSIC PLAYING]
MICHELLE KRAEMER: I'm Michelle
Kraemer, Global Strategy
Lead for Cloud for Marketing.
And I'm here today with Matt
Matyas from Google Marketing
Platform to talk to you about
how Google's Ads and Cloud
products work together to help
you create delightful customer
experiences.
Now before we get
started, I'd love
to get a sense for who we have
here in the room this morning.
How many of you are
on data and analytics
teams inside of your companies?
And specifically,
maybe some of you
working on marketing analytics.
A few hands, good.
And who here is in an IT
team supporting the marketing
department?
Welcome.
Do we have any
partners in the room?
Great.
And how about agencies?
And last, but definitely
not least, other marketing
technology companies?
Welcome.
Well, there's a
broad cross-section
of folks here in the room.
But one of the things
that we all have in common
is that we're also
all consumers.
So I wanted to just
take a minute of time
to think about the challenge
that marketing data
silos presents to us in
our lives as consumers.
And I'd like to start
with a real life example.
Not too long ago, I
undertook the adventure
of renovating 100 plus
year old house here
in San Francisco, where I live.
That is not my house,
but that is actually
my bathroom in a half
state of demolition,
which thankfully I never
had to use in quite
that level of exposure.
Well as anyone who's ever
done a renovation knows,
it involves a lot
of decision making
and a lot of
picking of fixtures.
Things that you've never even
heard the names of before.
Can anyone relate
to this experience?
A few brave souls
in the audience.
Well, my project
was no different.
And one of the things
that I had to pick
as part of this renovation
was the bathroom vanity,
that cabinet that goes
underneath your sink.
And so I've done a
little bit of shopping.
I had all my
measurements at hand
and was ready to go out
and see what was available.
And I ended up on the website
of a retailer I had shopped
with before and found the
exact right size and style
of that vanity,
purchased it online,
and was really
excited to go to sleep
knowing I'd checked something
off of a very long list.
But it turns out
that that next day, I
got a call from the retailer
saying, that item actually
was not available and it
wouldn't be anytime soon.
And to make matters worse,
an ad for that very vanity
started following me
around the internet.
I see some chuckles
over here, so it
sounds like folks can relate
to having had that experience.
As you can imagine, it was
disappointing in that I
wanted to buy that item but it
wasn't available for me to buy.
Well about a week
later, I ended up
in that retailer's
physical store
and found a vanity that
I liked just as much.
And as I was shopping
and checking out,
I opted into their
email marketing lists.
But I started to get emails
for bedroom furniture, which
was way outside of the
scope of my project.
In fact, if you'd seen my
living conditions at the time,
you'd know that that was
definitely not an option.
And now a year
later plus, I am now
getting ads for
bathroom faucets.
And I definitely am happy
I did the renovation,
but not interested in doing
another one anytime soon.
Now this kind of
experience is frustrating
and it felt like the brand
wasn't in tune with my needs
and my experiences.
I could only imagine what this
could be like in the future
if that brand would consider
all of the interactions I
had with them, not just in that
moment, but in the years prior.
And use that
understanding to customize
the interactions
they were having
with me every step of the way.
Now I'm not alone
in this desire.
Harvard Business Review took
a look at customer analytics
and found that the
stakes are high.
Customers today respond to
experiences that are timely,
targeted, and tailored to their
specific needs and reject those
that aren't.
I can tell you from
personal experience
that it did not take long
for me to unsubscribe
from that email list once
I got that first message.
We also know that this is
having a real business impact.
In an HBR survey, 44%
of survey responses
said that the use of
customer analytics
generates significant
revenue growth.
So we know that there
is business impact here
and that consumers really desire
this level of customization.
So why is this not what our
experience is all the time?
Well, the reason is firstly,
that all the information
that a marketer would
need to be able to tailor
the experience of a
consumer is spread
across many different systems
within their organization.
You can think of my
example where even
the inventory system and the
web CMS were not in sync.
Now to be truly
relevant, you also
need to look beyond
your first party data
to third party
data that might be
useful in terms of getting
a holistic picture of what's
actually happening.
Things like weather patterns
and economic indicators.
Siloed data means it's
hard to get insights.
And it also means
that marketing teams
have to start thinking beyond
their particular channels
and silos.
For example, a team that
focuses mostly on ads campaigns,
needs to start thinking
beyond ads data alone.
Now bringing all of your data
together across these silos
is really the first step
in the data journey.
Once that data is all
together in one place,
you can transform it to
be ready for analysis,
analyze it to generate
insights, and use those insights
across your organization
to create better customer
experiences.
This is fundamentally
what we set out
to achieve with
Cloud for Marketing.
Creating solutions to help
enterprises like yours
create delightful
customer experiences
from your data and
marketing technology.
Now we've had a
number of sessions
over the course
of this week that
have focused on
how to help you get
value out of your first
party data with Google Cloud.
And I will encourage you to
check them out on YouTube.
We'll put a list of them at
the end of this presentation.
As well as to come
by our booth, which
is in the showcase
for the rest of today.
I also recommend specifically
looking at the DA 101 session,
where we had customer examples
of success stories of creating
these kinds of experiences.
From brands like Ulta,
American Eagle, and Colgate.
For this session, we're going
to specifically focus on
how Google Marketing
Platform and Google
Cloud can work better
together to help you create
great customer experiences.
Working collaboratively
across our products,
we can help you
do three things--
understand the customer journey,
predict marketing outcomes,
and personalize the experience
at all touch points.
Google Marketing
Platform enables
you to build better digital ad
campaigns, planning, buying,
measuring, and optimizing the
digital ad experience and web
experience all in one place
to drive business growth.
And Google Cloud helps you
supercharge your customer
and marketing data,
bringing data together
across all touch points,
not only ads and web data,
but also CRM data, email
data, loyalty data, billing
data, and more.
And analyzing that
data at scale.
Now I'd like to turn it over to
Matt to talk a little bit more
about Google Marketing
Platform in detail.
MATT MATYAS: Thank
you so much, Michelle.
And hello, everybody.
As Michelle mentioned,
my name is Matt Matyas,
and I'm a Product Manager for
Google Marketing Platform.
And I'm thrilled to be here
to talk to you all today
about what Google Marketing
Platform is capable of
and how it can help
you and your companies
get value through all of
your marketing programs.
Let's start with an overview
of Google Marketing Platform.
At the highest
level, the platform
is a collection of
products that helps
you get much more value out
of your marketing programs.
Let's go through each
of the seven products
that are within, as you
can see here on screen.
We're going to start with
Display & Video 360, which
is our product for planning and
buying your display and video
campaigns.
And this is actually true
across the entire internet,
as there's a large
network of sites
that you can target through
Display & Video 360.
Search Ads 360 works
very similarly,
except that it's
targeting search ads
and search engines that
you can run search ads on.
And to note, this isn't just
including Google's search
engine.
This is including many of
the most popular search
engines across the internet.
Next is Google Analytics 360.
Google Analytics 360
helps you understand
how your customers are
engaging with your websites
and your mobile apps.
It's a critical set of
data to really understand
deeply how your customers are
engaging with your products.
Data Studio is our
reporting product
that allows you to pull data
in from many different sources,
including Google Cloud,
and then visualize
that in interesting ways.
It also makes it very easy
to share that data broadly
within your organization
and your other teammates
that you're working with.
Optimize 360 helps
you AB experiments
so you can customize content
for different groups of people
and find out which
combination of content's
going to work best
for your customers.
Surveys 360 lets you do
market research at scale.
If you are running a
new product program,
or if you have made
any significant changes
to your company's
brand, and you want
to measure the impact on
customer perceptions on that,
Surveys 360 allows you
to very easily do that.
And finally, Tag Manager
360 is a tagging product
that helps to automate
the process of updating
and launching new tags on
your websites and apps.
What used to take in the
past potentially months
to get a tag deployed now
can be automated and launched
in near real-time.
Great.
So now that we've taken a
look at what Google Marketing
Platform is all about
and the products within,
I want to walk you
through a real customer
example of how they got value
from Google Marketing Platform.
And for this
example, we're going
to take a look at Sprint,
a large telecommunications
company.
Hopefully many of you in the
room are familiar with them.
Sprint, just like many other
telecommunications companies,
they offer a lot of
services and products
to their customers for
mobile communications.
The switching costs
for a customer
to switch from one
telecommunications company
to another are
actually very low now.
So what that means
is companies have
to compete very hard to
keep their customers happy
and show the value.
And so Sprint's
marketing team was
challenged with trying
to keep and retain
more of their customers.
So what they did is
they actually they
joined together two of their
teams, their analytics team
and their marketing
team, and had
them collaborate
to run a program
to try to reduce
their churn rates.
So what they did is
they took a look at,
within all of their
data, their analytics
data from their website
and their apps, what kind
of signals could
predict a customer that
was likely to churn.
And what they found
was a couple factors
were pretty good predictors
of a customer likely to churn.
Things like a customer turning
off automatic bill pay,
or a customer who stops
engaging with their mobile app.
So what they did is
inside of Analytics 360,
they created an
audience for just users
who met that exact criteria.
Then they shift that audience
over to Display & Video
360, where they ran an
ad program targeted just
to those users to try to
remind them of the value
that Sprint offers and keep
them within their network.
And the results, you
can see on screen here.
They had a fantastic
10% reduction in churn.
If you think about just
how much cheaper it
is to retain an existing
customer than it
is to acquire a new one, this
is pretty significant impact.
So we just highlighted
one of the ways
that a couple of products
within Google Marketing Platform
can work better together to
drive more value for you.
We also have a lot
of additional ways
that the products
can be combined
to deliver further
marketing value for you.
And that's why we've built what
we call an Integration Center.
And inside of the
Integration Center,
that's where we're highlighting
a lot of these integrations,
and helping you
become aware of them,
and take advantage,
and get them set up.
What I'm going to do
next is run a live demo
and show you what the
Integration Center looks like.
So if we can switch over
to my laptop, perfect.
What you will do is
you'll start by going
to your favorite search engine
and searching for a marketing
platform.
Take a look down at
the search results.
And here is the Google
marketing platform.
Great.
Now you come to our
home page, where
you can learn all about
Google Marketing platform
and the products within.
And when you're ready to get
started, click the blue button
to sign on it.
This takes you
into an experience
we call Google
Marketing Platform Home.
Here you can get quick links
into the products within Google
Marketing Platform
that you're using,
as well as have access
to a series of functions
we built to better tie
these products together.
Right now I'm going to
demo the Integration
Center for all of you.
Once you launch
this, you're going
to see a few different
sections here,
starting with what we call
the integrations gallery.
And the integrations
gallery is going
to show you all the different
possible integrations that you
could create.
And then down below,
we have sections
that are tailored to you, as an
individual user in a company,
that will show you all the
products and integrations you
are working with right now.
Let's start by looking at
this gallery a little bit more
deeply.
Here you can see,
we've highlighted
some of our most
popular integrations.
You can read a little
bit about them,
click to learn more,
or even take action
and start getting going with
that integration right now.
Here you can see Display & Video
360 along with Analytics 360,
the very integration that
Sprint used in their program.
We also have various tabs that
will list all the integrations
by product.
And you can see, as
you click through,
we not only list integrations
within Google Marketing
platform, but we also
highlight prominent third party
integrations as well.
One in particular I
want to highlight here
is inside of Analytics.
It's possible to link
your Analytics 360
accounts to BigQuery.
And what you can do
is you can actually
export all of your
analytics data
into BigQuery for
all of the power
and the rich querying
capabilities of BigQuery.
And when you're ready
to get that set up,
you simply click the
Add Integration button.
It asks you which
website or mobile
app you would like to target.
Now let's go ahead
for this demo,
we're going to look at the
Google Merchandise Store.
And you simply
follow the prompts
to load up the experience
that guides you
through creating this link.
You'll see what will load
in just a moment here
is a few steps of a wizard that
asks you a series of questions
for how you want to
export the data out
of analytics and into BigQuery.
One of the first things
you're going to do
is input an ID of
your BigQuery project.
Then you select the
source analytics
view where the data is
going to come out of.
There are various alerts
that will be triggered.
And so you want to pick who is
going to be receiving those.
And finally, there are
a couple of settings
that control how the data
is going to flow across.
So you'd simply
read that and choose
the appropriate option for you.
And that's it.
Once you've done
this, you're now set.
Your data is going
to be exported out
of Analytics into BigQuery.
And you'll be able to do
your rich analysis there.
I'm going to return back to the
Integration Center experience.
As I was highlighting
a little bit earlier,
you can also see the
products that you're
using within Google
Marketing Platform, as well
as the integrations,
the product pairs,
that you're using right now.
All of this is interactive.
You can click on
any part of this.
So let's click into the
Analytics section, for example.
And we're going to see a list
of all of your properties
that you're working with.
And then off to the
right is a series
of columns here for
each of the products
that you could
potentially integrate
with those properties.
For this demo, we're to look for
the Google Merchandise Store.
That's our demo account
that we'd like to showcase.
And you're able to see here, for
our various Google Merchandise
Store properties, the
other products that they're
integrated with.
So these numbers mean that
this particular property has
been integrated three times
with Display & Video 360,
once with Search Ads 360, five
times with Campaign Manager,
and so on.
If you realize, oh, wow,
some of my properties
haven't been integrated,
you can simply
figure that out
really quickly here
and follow the prompts
to go ahead and set up
that integration.
So we've tried to make the whole
Integration Center experience
both educational to help
you understand what's
possible and then
very actionable
so you can follow the links
and set these integrations up
for yourself.
Great.
And with that, I'm going
to switch back over
to the main slides.
So we showcased a few different
integrations that we offer.
And there are
plenty more of that
are in the Integration Center
that you can take a look at.
I'm going to highlight a few
more very briefly here for you.
The first one is with Search
Ads 360 and Analytics 360.
It's possible to export
your Search Ads data out
of the product and
into Analytics 360,
where what you can do is marry
the two data sets together
to get rich insights on how your
marketing campaigns are truly
performing.
Within Search Ads 360, you get
rich data on the ad campaigns
that you're running.
Keyword-level data
and bidding data
that you're selecting
for your programs.
And then in
Analytics 360, you'll
have rich data on your
websites and your apps.
Which pages or screens that
your customers are going to,
how long they're spending,
if they ultimately convert.
When you marry those
two data sets together,
you get a holistic picture
of your customer journeys
and the performance.
Next, we have Analytics 360
with Display & Video 360.
This is the very integration
that we looked at earlier
with Sprint, where you
create a high value audience
inside of analytics
and target ads
against it inside of
Display & Video 360.
With Sprint you saw that they
had targeted folks that they
thought were about to churn.
Another common one that you'll
see as customers will identify
shopping cart
abandoners, people who
are about to purchase a product
from you but for some reason
decide to leave.
They're a high
value group that you
may want to re-market to and get
them to come back, potentially
as customers.
And finally, we have Analytics
360 and Optimize 360.
It's also possible to share your
audiences out of Analytics 360
into Optimize and then target
an AB experiment to them.
This helps you to really
refine the content
that you have on your
sites and make sure
that you're offering
exactly the right content
your customers want to see.
Within Google
Marketing Platform,
we recognize that there are
many teams of people and lots
of individuals who are
going to be working together
to accomplish your
marketing goals.
And so accordingly, we believe
that it's important for us
to build strong collaboration
tools and capabilities
into our products.
And to showcase an
example of that,
I'm going to show you two screen
captures here of Data Studio.
You're seeing what two
people who are loading up
the same report would see.
On the left, you have
a user who is making
edits live to the report.
And then on the right,
the user you'll see
is able to see the
updates in near real-time
as that person A is
making those updates.
It's also important to highlight
that Data Studio connects
to many data sources.
And so there are
quite a few ways
to import cloud data
into Data Studio
and visualize data in
really interesting ways.
It's one great example as to
how Google Marketing Platform
and Google Cloud
work better together.
So with that, hopefully you've
got a great overview now
of how Google Marketing Platform
works and a couple of ideas
as to how your company might be
able to get some value from it.
And with that, I'm
going to turn it over
to Michelle, who
is going to walk it
through even more examples as to
how these two product platforms
can work better together.
MICHELLE KRAEMER: Thanks, Matt.
MATT MATYAS: You bet.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHELLE KRAEMER: As Matt
mentioned, when used together,
Google Marketing
Platform and Google Cloud
enhance each other.
You saw how you can export data
from Google Marketing Platform
into Google Cloud with
just a couple of clicks.
And the same is true for
other Google data sources,
such as Google Ads, Play
Store data, YouTube data,
Firebase data, and more.
Once that data is
in Google Cloud,
you can bring it together
with other first party data,
like data from your CRM
system, your e-commerce system,
or your billing system.
And as of this
week, that process
is also easier because
the BigQuery data transfer
service has been extended
to third party systems--
100 plus available
for you all today.
Once that data is
there, you can use
BigQuery to get
insights faster, as well
as use Google's powerful
machine learning tools
to find hidden insights
that might be there
within your first party data.
And you can action those
insights by visualizing them
back in Data Studio, as Matt
showed, as well as third party
tools like Looker and Tableau.
And finally, you can
action those insights
back into the
Google Ads ecosystem
through Google Marketing
Platform and Google Ads,
using some of the integrations,
like the GA 360 and Display
& Video 360, integrations
that Matt discussed,
as well as use third party
tools for activation,
such as SendGrid and
email, to hopefully make
that email experience better
than the one I described
in my example.
As you can see, Google Marketing
Platform and Google Cloud
compliment each other.
And Google Cloud also helps
you get more value out
of the other marketing
tools that you use.
Now to help you get
to that value quickly,
we've put together and
built out a set of use cases
to help you get started.
And you can learn more
about any of these use cases
by stopping by the booth
or sending an email
to the email address
that is included
at the end of this presentation.
So let's take one of those
use cases for starters.
Purchase prediction.
This was the thing that was
missing from my renovation
story.
As a business, you want to
be able to accurately predict
what is the next
product or service
that a customer is
interested in buying
so that you can deliver better
experiences than the one I
described.
Now if any team of marketers
wants to do this today,
they'd likely have to get two to
three technical teams involved
to get the data.
And it might take
a couple of weeks
to bring it together in a format
that's useful for analysis.
Depending on your
business, by this time
the customer may have moved
on in their decision making.
And so the insights
you're going to get
are going to be less relevant.
Now we make this
easier through the data
imports that I mentioned.
As well as third
data cleansing tools,
like Data Prep, and the speed
and scale of BigQuery, that
make it faster to
get to insights
the marketing teams
can actually use.
And some of the things
that are possible to do
within the Google Ads
ecosystem and beyond
include things like finding
lookalike audiences,
increasing bids on generic
keywords for an item
a customer is likely to buy,
and understanding site behavior
and customizing the web
experience accordingly.
And here is what a
high level architecture
looks like for how you can use
Google Ads and Google Cloud
products together
to solve for the use
case of purchase prediction.
Now at this point, you may
be thinking, OK, I get it.
Customers are asking for
personalized, customized
experiences and this
has real business impact
if we are able to solve this
problem of breaking down
these data silos, bringing
data together, and analyzing it
at scale.
But I live in a multi cloud
environment and why should
I do this with Google?
So I want to just walk
through a couple of areas
where we're different
specifically
for Cloud for Marketing.
First, we're a leader in
smart analytics as a service.
Forester rated Google
as the only leader
in their insight platforms
as a service report.
We're also building solutions
that are specifically designed
to meet marketers' needs.
So an example are the use cases
that I just walked through,
as well as making it easier
to use these solutions
themselves through tools like
the BigQuery data transfer
service, as well as things
like allowing a marketer
to build machine learning
models using BigQuery ML
and doing that right in SQL.
And while we're on the
topic of ML and AI,
Google is a leader in this area.
We have over 7,500 projects
that are powered by AI inside
of Google, including some of
Google's consumer products,
like Search, Maps,
Assistant, and more.
And we've embedded ML and AI
into the core of our solutions
in Google Cloud to
make it accessible
and enable those
transformative experiences.
So in addition to the Cloud
for Marketing specific ways
that we're different, we
also build on all the ways
that Google Cloud
itself is different.
And you've heard
a lot about this
over the course of the
week in our keynotes,
so I won't go into
it in great detail.
But just to highlight a
few of our strengths here.
Security.
Fully automated operations
and openness are in our DNA.
And lastly, we bring
in the best of Google
to solving marketing use cases.
Things like using the technology
of the Google Cloud Vision API
to be able to solve
for unstructured data
and getting value out of that
visual unstructured data.
Plus Google teams have
years of experience
in working with
enterprises of all kinds
across the globe to solve
marketing challenges using
Cloud and Ads technology.
This means that Google can
help you really accelerate
your digital transformation.
So we've talked a lot about how
we're helping enterprises today
by leveraging our
products better together.
And I want to just give you a
sense for what we're building.
How we're turning that linear
data journey into a flywheel
that can keep pace with customer
expectations and decision
making.
The Cloud for Marketing
console is our first step
in making it possible
for marketers
to solve for use
cases in a way that's
faster, simpler, and smarter,
and it's available in alpha
now.
If you're interested in
seeing more about the console
and asking questions in detail,
you can do that at our booth.
And there's product managers
and engineers on site
to help answer your questions.
Within the existing
Cloud console,
we've created this Cloud
for Marketing console
to make it more
engaging and interactive
for non-technical users.
When a user opens
the console, they'll
see a dashboard that will have
available data sources based
on the data they've
brought into BigQuery,
as well as built in tagging
and access controls.
We have templated queries
that make it easier
for you to do to get value
out of your data and derive
insights.
And predictive
models that help you
understand and predict customer
behavior and drive business
outcomes.
And finally, we have links
to the Data Studio dashboards
that Matt described
that are built directly
into the console as a template.
We make bringing your
data into BigQuery
faster by providing
tools that give you
the step by step instructions
you need directly
in the console.
And managing all of your
marketing-related data
is simpler with built in
tagging and access controls.
You can also maintain data
privacy and security down
to the column level for
sensitive data and PII.
And finally, the
console provides smarter
insights about your marketing
customers and products
by leveraging templated
queries and the same models
that power Google's services
with no coding needed.
Now as we build products
like the console
to help make it possible to
solve for marketing use cases
faster, simpler,
and smarter, we're
also trying to make it
easier for enterprises
to get the most value of how our
products work better together.
As an example of this, we
include templated queries
for queries that you
might need to run
around Google Analytics
or other web analytics
data in the console.
And we also have
seamless integrations
into Data Studio built in.
We're excited to see
what kinds of experiences
you all build by using Google
Cloud and Google Ads products
effectively better together.
And I want to give you a
little bit of inspiration here
and bring up one of our
customers, Kenny Wu, who
is Vise President of
product at Essence,
to tell you how he's doing it.
[APPLAUSE]
KENNY WU: Thank you.
Hello, I'm Kenny.
I look after the
product team at Essence.
And today I'd like to talk
to you a bit about how we've
used machine learning
in Google Cloud
and activated that to
create better customer
experiences via the
Google Marketing Platform.
Essence is an advertising
agency, part of GroupM and WPP.
And we're focused on
creating better experiences
and making better
decisions using data.
We work with some of
the largest advertisers
in the world, Target, NBC
Universal, T-Mobile, and Google
to name a few.
Today I'll be taking you through
an example of how we customized
ad creative with Google, but we
do this for many of our clients
across many industries.
So first.
The world right now
is buzzing with talks
of artificial intelligence
and machine learning.
The science of making
things smart and the science
of getting computers to
do something without being
programmed with the rules.
While there's a lot of
theory that's going on.
I'd like to share a concrete
example of how we brought this
to life.
So a few months ago,
Google Marketing
came to us with a challenge.
How do we help consumers
better understand
the power of Google Assistant?
Specifically this
idea of how a system
can offer helpful information at
the moment when it's relevant.
So a good example of
this is in the kitchen.
Any home cooks out there?
People that are
interested, yeah.
So I was making pancakes the
other day and for those science
geeks out there we
know that you leaven
this dough with a bit of
soda and a bit of acid.
And I was replacing
vinegar with lemon juice.
But I had my hands
covered in flour
and forgot what
the conversion was.
Great moment to find some
information via Assistant.
So what we did is we took
this idea of helping people
in the right moments find the
information that they need,
specifically around a recipe
section in a partnership
with The Guardian.
What we looked at
specifically was demonstrating
how Google Assistant could
recommend relevant recipes
based on the recipes
that you're looking at.
So this idea of
contextual advertising
has existed for a long time.
But usually, you actually don't
have that much interesting
information.
You know a web page where
something is served,
roughly what the topic
looks like, potentially
where the user is located.
And if you're lucky, you get
keyword-level information.
So something we
might have considered
with just that information is
to do some text categorization.
Let's categorize sweet keywords
and savory ones and then
recommend an
accompanied recipe that
would be relevant to something
sweet or something savory.
However, you could end up
with some weird results.
Pancakes, which for me is
a sweet breakfast food,
can also mean kimchi pancakes.
And a recommendation
for something
like orange-infused maple syrup
would not be very appropriate.
So we took a look at
the other information
that we had at hand,
which was the pictures
of the recipes themselves.
And took a look at how we
could take this content
to customize our messaging.
We used AutoML in Cloud,
and specifically Vision,
to train a model on identifying
sweet and savory foods using
the imagery alone.
So without text analysis.
Took a little time.
About 200 images
that needs to be hand
categorized into
sweet and savory.
But afterwards,
we're very accurately
able to predict whether or not
something was sweet or savory.
And that allowed us to come
up with much more contextually
relevant messaging, without the
weirdness of kimchi pancakes
in maple syrup.
So putting this all together
with text analysis and image
analysis, we're
able to create ads
that appeared customized
and conversational with just
content and context.
This can then be
extended in the future
by bringing in the first
party and third party
data that was mentioned earlier
to create even better ads.
While this feels
great having ads
that make sense, that are
relevant to the content that's
next to you, it has big
business impact as well.
We're able to create
thousands of ads
in a matter of hours across
each individual recipe page.
We also applied similar
methodology on things
like movie reviews, restaurant
reviews, travel to name a few.
And we saw a major
lift in response
based on more relevant ads.
In fact, we saw a 9.5% lift
in category understanding.
And this is interesting
because that
means that one in 10 people who
saw these ads versus a control
had a much better understanding
of what Google Assistant could
do for them on a
day by day basis.
So how did we do this?
So here's the
technical architecture
behind all of this.
What we did is on
a twice daily basis
collect information
from The Guardian
in a JSON file about all the
news articles, recipe articles,
reviews, et cetera
that were published.
And we analyzed that
information in Google Cloud.
First off, we took a
look at the content.
Every brand is different.
So some brands want to
appear next to a large swath
of content, some very narrow.
So we actually trained an AutoML
natural language processing
model to determine whether or
not the content was appropriate
for that brand.
Second, we used the
Natural Language
API to extract salient keywords,
such as in the last example,
I think ginger, here
a salient keyword,
from the text in the recipe.
Further, we used
the visual analysis,
as I mentioned before, to
determine sweet and savory.
Finally, we took a
look at additional data
we could use to bring in
and enrich the information
that we had already.
A good example of
this is Maps data
that we used around
restaurant reviews.
Given that The Guardian is
focused very much in the UK,
we looked at where a person's
location was and whether or not
the restaurant was
within the city.
At which point we would
recommend a restaurant
in a particular neighborhood.
Or if it's outside of
the city, and we would
indicate which town it was in.
All this combined
together allowed
us to construct a
customized copy that
was then fed and activated in
the Google Marking Platform.
So the two pieces of the
Marking Platform that we used,
Studio, where we
created the dynamic ads,
combined the customized
text with the ad imagery.
And then we serve those ads via
Google Marketing Platform's DV
360.
With a special connection
with The Guardian,
we're able to determine which
pages would be served as we're
buying impressions
through DV 360,
so therefore we could customize
the content that would show up.
So I hope that this
short example inspires
you to take a close
look at the data
that you have on hand, not
just the data that you might
be using today, to
create better experiences
and make better decisions for
your customers, your clients,
and your team
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
MICHELLE KRAEMER: Thank
you so much, Kenny.
You've managed to figure out how
to make this entire room even
hungrier when we're the only
things probably standing
between you all and lunch.
But it was very inspiring.
So if you are interested
in what you heard today
around building better customer
experiences using your data
and marketing technology,
you can learn more about this
by checking out all of the other
sessions that will be posted
on YouTube for this event.
And these are the titles here.
As well as visit
us in the booth,
and we're interested
to hear from you,
so you can reach our team via
the email address on screen.
Thank you so much
for being here.
And then feedback is a gift.
So please, before
you leave, don't
forget to rate the session and
tell us what resonated with you
and what you'd love
to hear more of.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]